olá meu nome é gustavo e hoje eu vou
dizer em como ter mais verde no planeta
eu escolhi esse tema porque às vezes é a
minha família e chegamos no dia de
planta colocando um vasinho esperamos
crescer até poder plantar fora de casa e
espero que depois da minha apresentação
moisés também colaborem foi pequena um
exemplo que eu queria do que eu faço é
minha árvore da fortuna que um dia eu
ganhei ela no inglês da minha escola e
quando nem era muito pequena mas ao
menos desse tamanho não muito menor do
que eu porque eu também era bebê
mas agora embora nossos cuidados ela já
tá até maior do que eu por exemplo que
eu queria dar a da minha orquídea que um
dia meu irmão vai descer no nosso pede
para jogar futebol
ele encontrou uma orquídea jogada no
lixo sabendo que minha mãe gosta muito
das plantas
ele trouxe la para um apartamento minha
mãe tem uma parte da banda já estava
morta então ela cortou dando assim mais
força para a planta e do tempo depois
ela já favoreceu então uma pessoa teria
jogado fora uma planta que poderia
florescer e deixar nosso planeta mais
verde prevendo que eu queria down é da
minha macieira que um dia eu fui lá
carnaval na casa da minha tia e eu comia
uma maçã
depois que eu terminei a maçã ele também
tinha já estava quase brotando
então minha mãe pediu um copinho eo
algodão e colocou a sementinha dentro do
algodão
depois que a gente chegou lá no
apartamento
minha mãe tirou semente de algodão e
colocou num vasinho pequeno onde tinha
espaço para crescer um pouco conosco
ficou muito grande para aquele vaso e me
colocou em um vaso maior onde ela podia
trazer o atleta até o teto da nossa
varanda que era onde ela estava quando
ela chegou até da varanda a gente pensou
em ligar para um amigo nosso que tem um
quintal com muito verde parece até um
sítio
ele pegou a planta e deixou ela no vaso
até acostumar com o local e com a
temperatura
depois ele
com ela na terra onde ela ainda está
plantada vocês sabiam que comeu uma maçã
é muito importante
tem até uma frase em inglês que diz
rodei que perdeu alterou e que significa
que se você comeu uma maçã por dia
você não fica doente claro que mesmo
comendo essa saudável ainda dá pra ficar
doente mas esse é o melhor jeito de
prevenir minha parceira ainda não deu os
frutos porque eu vi que nas feiras
começam a da maçã no final dos três anos
aos inclui ainda está começando cinco
anos e deve cair mais um pouco e
recordam muita maçã com dez e 30 anos
podem dar dos 30 tão 50
com esse exemplo da madeira sempre que
eu ea minha família encontramos uma
mudinha deplan tomar sementinha de
alguma fruta
a gente coloca em um vazio e espera
crescer para poder levantar fora de casa
se for amor que a gente chamava na área
obrigado pela atenção em você e eu
espero que depois disso faço hoje a
minha família fazemos ou até melhor